the nominees for performance by an
actress in a supporting role are Maggie
Smith's in a room with a view Piper
Laurie and children of a lesser God
Dianne Wiest and Hannah and her sisters
Mary Elizabeth mastrantonio in the color
of money Tess Harper and crimes of the
Hutt
and and the winner is dan we stand
gee this isn't like I imagined but it
would be in the bathtub um I first of
all want to say how very proud I am to
be nominated with for women whose work
is so wonderful and I'm still making a
movie with woody my fourth movie with
him so um I'm still working with the
same people I worked with in Hanna the
same crew the same cameraman the same
designer is the same great
cinematographer Carlo De Palma um the
same producer Bobby green Hut the same
drivers were all there and I think on
behalf of all of us and also on behalf
of the actors Maureen O'Sullivan Lloyd
Nolan uh Barbara Hershey and beautiful
Mia Farrow
thank you my mom my brothers my family
and my dearest friend Sam Cohn thank you
very much
you